hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to a late-night drink I
can't wait to play more I love this
custom story so much but anyway the
demons are invading every part of his
mind so let's go to the heart of the
mind the minds heart with which in the
mind resides to face the demons as hard
as we can ooh well this isn't what I was
like oh it's a library that makes sense
okay so that's locked I need to find a
key what soon
sure I see a book of horror stories on
the table oh I've read some of these I
wonder if I can find my favorite it
should be good okay oh man that's a lot
once the diamond a small quiet village
could be found a small quiet people the
people weren't small in stature but in
demeanor the very few times anyone would
happen in the village either passing
through a perhaps by to trade they would
always know the same things about the
villagers they kept to themselves spoken
short timid sentences but above all
people noted that they seemed kind they
welcomed outsiders under one condition
do not go into the woods most people
wrote it off as local superstition this
was until one day a young man came to
the village he was a very charismatic
man that everyone took to unfortunately
he was also very brash and ignored the
warnings about the forest he entered the
place against the warnings of the local
blacksmith where's the black bird oh
he's right there barely the oldest man
in the village also only one old enough
to remember what happened the last time
someone entered those evil woods he told
the young Mandan evil lurked deep in the
woods that would possess incorrupt and
even the kind is so good God turning him
against his fellow man the boy laughed
it off and left to see what wonders the
forest may hold he did not return for
three nights during which the blacksmith
berry dated his door from the inside
nerds the town's folk to do the same
unfortunately time had faded harsh facts
in the passing knowledge then the
whispered rumors and finally half
believed superstition the townfolk
worried that the about the young man but
partially out of fear and mostly out of
disbelief in their own superstitions he
ignored the Smiths warning the third
night came and with it evil the
blacksmith stayed in his work ship
barricaded and terrified and listen as
someone entered the quiet village and
slaughtered everyone within then there
came a banging at his door oh but we
knew it would take more than a man or
even a beast to break down his door he
was still afraid until daybreak finally
came in with the banging it stopped Oh
with it the banging stopped the
unfortunate young man possessed by a
great evil at luck way too many
wait a minute ah ah however they say
that if you go to that village at night
listen closely you can still hear him
screaming or his vile victim screaming
Natalie where's the blacksmith where's
the blacksmith yeah yes oh I'm so glad I
actually read that oh I was close I was
like it was so long as it oh god but
yeah yeah I love this go to Norway I
love it oh my god that's so amazing
they took a long time but I'm glad you
all stuck with it or I'm glad I stuck
with it anyway
oh now to spend forever trying to find
the ding dong damn key I guess I guess
this guy the guy who made it really did
I have me in mind when he was cooking it
up oh my god you got to be kidding me oh
no way okay I thought those who were
pull books for a second they're not just
random books okay but either way thank
you so much maker this game for making
this it is one of my favorite and these
are custom stories ever
hello key found you yeah got the chest
key I didn't see a chest though this
just okay boop boop Jesse oh really oh
that's how it's gonna be I knew it
couldn't be that easy so I gotta look
for four keys does that count the one
that I already have or is that not count
that one
oh my goodness I am gonna be here for
days I bet it's behind some of these
books aren't it the ones that are
removable otherwise there wouldn't be so
many removable ones huh that were you
telling me you son of a [ __ ] I take
back everything that I just said about
you you son of a [ __ ]
oh you ass ah it's like that other
developer of the Hemnes comes some
storia the great work dick punching
party extraordinaire oh my god you got
to be joking me
it better not actually be in one of
these Oh God
oh my god I'm gonna be here so long oh
oh my god oh my god I can't oh my god no
don't please I don't wanna I don't wanna
I don't wanna over a ball I don't wanna
ah this is how I die this is how a guy
endlessly searching for crap that's not
there Hey look I found another one the
only other one and that only took
forever all good I'm so good oh good for
you Oh
you cannot do this to me I was enjoying
your game and now I hate it I hate it I
hate it so much
where's a damn key ah oh god damn it
found another one that's three where's
the last one guys I have literally been
looking for about 15 minutes I can't
believe this this is the most bull ass
bull I went from really liking the game
to really aiding it this is awful game
mechanic this is awful this is the worst
this is what you shouldn't
do right after I am in such enjoying it
mood miss this sucks ass god dammit look
at all the books I've pulled out [ __ ] oh
oh my god you have got to be kidding me
good god please let that be the last
[ __ ] one Oh God
I'm not gonna read this I had the
strangest experience local surprising
friend party pipe passed around didn't
know plant called Hachi Maura
Oh goddamn it takes him home with me
some sort of hallucinogenic amongst the
pile seemingly meaningless ramblings you
come across Korea curious line shield
shield bird shield bird bird
oh my voice is going god damn it I've
been trying to keep my voice for a few
days now and god damn this [ __ ] thing
[ __ ] it shield shield bird shield bird
bird it's written in my notes anyway God
my voice has been going I've been trying
to keep my voice together for like I
don't even have what am I supposed to do
now I don't have anything what am I
supposed to do now is there a key in
here oh my god you got to be joking
what am i what what am i what am I
supposed to do oh oh I get it I get it
[ __ ] alright yeah yeah so shield or I
get it okay
this is clever yeah it's clever
yeah clever very good good job clever
oh I'm so angry
I do not even know how to describe how
angry on I need to actually take a
breather for a bit cuz I cannot handle
this right now okay alright I'm back my
voice is seriously going again
I see refor the past three days my voice
has steadily been getting worse and I've
been trying to hold on to it but god
damn it okay I'm back I'm ready
what have you got for me ready another
lock thing do I have to find another key
oh it's right there alright it's been 24
years since she has been taken with me I
would be lying if I said I didn't try to
move on I would be lying if I said I
ever really could though I don't know
how hard this is for other people
bla bla bla man is convinced okay so
this is where he started dipping into
hallucinogenics he's probably the guy
that started making the wines more I
wanted to believe I have charted a
flight to that region wait what oh man I
got dim mass hallucination Strout on by
that drug hold on the ticket he's trying
to go find it so that he can go lose
himself in his hallucinations that's
what he's doing it anyway I abandoned my
son years ago in a fit of selfish rage
never ever I've any time I've ever
thought to track him down I've only
managed to remind myself how on foot I
would be as a father made up my mind
alcohol helped I will leave tomorrow
it's raining again okay
desk key got it why is my mouse going
all over the place there we go peace of
mind knowledge fantastic good job good
good
oh hi how's it going mr. face so the
plan turned out to be legit yes ik
succeeded in taking me from one the
other side like I intended then that's
what I drank wait why are we being
attacked if this is just the afterlife
are we in hell no a place much worse
that plant was never meant for this we
are in a place between life and death
where it lurk things much older than
heaven in hell
great I just wanted some vintage wine
and I got a freaking trip to something I
didn't read the rest of it okay alright
there's only one door open right now
let's just go selfishness that's right
okay selfishness selfishness selfishness
it is what sin selfishness is this where
he abandons his son to rip just shred
- thunk it didn't even make a sound BAM
[ __ ]
yeah that is selfishness there gonna be
another hidden key baby oh oh that was
it oh okay then I just don't know what
to do I am at my wit's end caring for a
child who's on your own is difficult and
you are in mourning on top of it it's
understandable
I'm sorry son we'll make sure he gets a
good home oh so he put it up for
adoption it's the baby I don't mean it
him up for adoption I'd rather not talk
about that memory if you say so man if
you say so
still a little peeved still he'll be a
little bit
I believe I'm starting to piece together
what happened here you used a mystical
plan to still do a more concentrated
form to have an out-of-body experience
but it was far too successful I never
dreamed that such horrors lurked in the
void all the more reason we need to
hurry agreed okay all right what have we
have here we've got anger and confusion
which would I like to try I actually
don't think I have time for either of
them so hi my voice man I didn't want my
voice to go anyway thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
now we
China
so every bar
love